I climbed the mountain yesterday.
Did you have a good time there?
Yes.
There were so many clouds above the mountain.
What did you do yesterday?
I went to the river and caught fish.
There was a small bridge over the river.
And there were many ducks on the river.
Wow.
I want to go there.
Polly got out of her cage and flew out the door.
What did she fly over and what did she see?
She saw some houses when she flew over the trees.
She saw a path when she flew over the houses.
She saw a pond when she flew over the path.
She saw a playground when she flew over the pond.
She saw some flowers when she flew over the playground.
Now Polly flew into her cage.
Phew, she was safe.